one of the
central questions that comes up almost
inevitably
and immediately in any introduction to
philosophy class or anything
similar to that where students are
getting
introduced to the vast discipline and
literature
of philosophy more or less for the first
time they've usually heard the word
but they're not quite sure what it is
they ask well what
is the definition of philosophy and it
makes good sense why people
want definitions we use them as
tools as intellectual devices for
demarcating what something
is and what it isn't very often
when we're teaching matters especially
outside of the field
of philosophy we give students
definitions
as starting points that then they can
move on from and and we do this a lot in
our primary and secondary education
things that people have to
memorize we're rewarded for learning the
definitions of things and being able to
regurgitate them and so there's a few
things to say about this the first
is that there is no agreed upon
definition of philosophy and when i say
agreed upon
i mean one where there's consensus among
all of the many practitioners even in
the present day
not to mention going backwards in time
or spreading ourselves out across
various
intellectual cultures so there is
there's a lot of definitions
but there's no definition singular
that everybody is in agreement on
the second thing is that we actually use
definitions or things like definitions
but not exactly the same
as tools in philosophies a lot of
philosophy is actually saying
what is the meaning of this what is what
is the best thing what is the essence
how do we
express it and so it's quite natural
that when somebody is starting out
in philosophy we should take that
activity
of seeking definitions as something we
would apply to the field
itself and this brings us to the third
point
in asking what is the definition
of philosophy we are engaged in what we
nowadays call
metaphilosophical activity
and inquiry and there's nothing wrong
with that
as a matter of fact that can be quite a
good exercise to carry out
but it has not generated over the years
in which people have been
engaged in that as i just mentioned any
sort of consensus definition
and it's important to recognize that you
are doing
philosophy in asking for the definition
of philosophy so you know the prospects
of
attaining a definition that everybody
will agree to are
actually pretty slim there's all sorts
of dodges that people do they say
well philosophy if we break it down
etymologically
the filo is love literally
friendship or desire for uh you know
fondness of
and then the sophos is wisdom
philosophy is the love of wisdom and
then you can say oh that's that's cool
what the hell does that mean right
because that could mean a lot of
different things
do you love wisdom in the sense that
you're seeking after it do you personify
it
as some philosophical and wisdom
traditions have usually in the form of
a woman that is being sought by the male
seeker of wisdom do you view wisdom as a
state within yourself so it's actually a
reflexive
activity is wisdom the collected
smart things that people have said
throughout the ages so that you would be
going through various texts and sayings
and proverbs
one thing we can say without having to
settle this right now
love of wisdom as a characterization of
philosophy does not really provide us
with any sort of adequate definition
and you could go to dictionaries if you
want to um
don't rely on dictionaries as a matter
of fact when you're
doing philosophy this is just a side
note it's never good to begin by saying
the you know so-and-so dictionary
defines
this term as etc etc because
usually in philosophy we're working with
a different sense
of the term than simply the dictionary
definition dictionaries only tell us
their historical documents
what people have meant by a term they
don't really
outline the essence that a term
is supposed to signify so you can find
all sorts of cool dictionary definitions
of philosophy
those are not really an adequate
starting point as well
i'd like to lead you through a whole
bunch of
interesting proposals for
defining philosophy and comment on a few
of them so you get
some idea of the vast range of ways
people have looked at this activity this
literature this discipline
that they are engaged in so
from ancient philosophers plato at one
point
defines philosophy as preparation
for death now that's kind of a startling
way of understanding it right i mean you
might say funeral planning would be
more like that than philosophy but
philosophy
is early on in the west
tied together with putting things into a
big perspective
the end point of which is death
aristotle plato student
at one point says the science of the
universal essence of that which is
actual
that's pretty abstract does that tell
you much of anything without
going into aristotle's texts probably
not
epicurus an activity which by words and
arguments secures the happy life this is
focusing
much more on the practical side of
philosophy
philosophy
as a way of life and you could
find similar statements from other
philosophers like the stoics
cicero the science of divine things and
the human
causes through which all these things
are contained a much more
metaphysical definition of philosophy
which refers us to
the higher matters the things that
determined
the universe and us as parts of that
and understanding them in terms of
causes
when we get to the medieval period
here's a few
the illumination of the intelligent mind
by the pure wisdom a kind of return and
recall to it
so that it seems that once the pursuit
of wisdom the pursuit of divinity
and the friendship of that pure mind
that is boethius
in the consolation of philosophy telling
us about that there's a lot involved in
that definition
notice love the pursuit of wisdom
pursuit of divinity
friendship of that of pure mind several
different aspects interconnected there
dante says philosophy is a loving
use of wisdom all kindy the
establishment of what is
true and right moving on to early modern
philosophers
miguel de montaigne has a single word
answer doubt
rene descartes says the study of wisdom
and by wisdom has meant not only
prudence
in everyday affairs but also a perfect
knowledge of the things that mankind is
capable of knowing
both for the conduct of life and the
preservation of health and the discovery
of all manner of skills a very
well worked out definition there which
you know you could
certainly agree with but not everybody's
going to buy that one
thomas hobbes also said the knowledge
acquired by reasoning from the manner of
the generation of anything to the
properties or from the properties to
some possible generation of the same
to the end to be able to produce as far
as matter and human force
permit such effects as human life
requires
so again a rather practically oriented
definition of philosophy but it involves
some
metaphysical understanding and inquiry
and analysis
learning how things are brought to be so
we can make them
happen like that later modern
philosophers
uh georg friedrich wilhelm william
friedrich hegel says
the actual cognition of that which in
truth is
okay so you know that that's a nice
abstract phrase
as well herbert spencer completely
unified knowledge now that's an
interesting one
because it points towards something that
was there
as an impulse in philosophy really from
the beginning
a kind of knowledge a kind of
understanding of things that would
actually provide the big picture and
unify the other kinds of knowledge
william want
the acquisition of such a general
conception of the world and of life as
will satisfy the exigencies
of the reason and the needs of the heart
exigencies are demands
of reason so vuent is is signifying
reason we have to satisfy reason and we
also have to satisfy
the needs of the heart of our emotional
side some definitions from analytic
anglo-american philosophers
g.e moore famously said when he was
asked what's philosophy
it's what all these are about gesturing
at his bookshelf right so
that's not much of a definition but it
is at least saying well where do you
find these
these uh bits of philosophy ludwig
wittgenstein
very famously called philosophy a fight
against the fascination
which forms of expression exert upon
ourselves he also called philosophy a
disease
that of which it should be the cure
right and then finally
rudolph kernapp one of the logical
positivists
from the vienna circle the logic of the
sciences again
this this sort of overarching
project where philosophy has something
to do with the
other disciplines and informs them in
some way
continental european philosophers um
fairness steinberg and the integral
study of the real
integral means comprehensive connecting
everything up together
ortega egassed a science without
presuppositions this is often
another aspect of philosophy that people
signal whereas all the other sciences
and disciplines
they buy into something at the start
with philosophy
we're supposed to attend to the
realities in front of us without making
presuppositions
that's the way at least some
philosophers have looked at it
habermas jurgen habermas says the
guardian of rationality pointing towards
a task for philosophy more than
a definition of philosophy
there are several others that we could
take a look at that i think would be
interesting for example american
pragmatist
and process philosophers josiah royce
said passions faith doubt and courage
the critical inquiry into what all these
things mean and imply
is philosophy so philosophy bears upon
all of these things that we often don't
view as rational
william james this is a really great
definition although
great in the sense of you know pithy and
expressing something
the unusual stubborn attempt unusually
stubborn attempt to think
clearly right so the philosopher is like
everybody else trying to think clearly
but they stick to it more and he doesn't
say they stick to it more by discipline
he
frames it in terms of stubbornness right
john dewey said inherently criticism
having its distinctive position among
various modes of criticism and its
generality
a criticism of criticisms as it were
philosophy is and can be nothing but
this critical operation and function
become aware of itself and its
implications pursued deliberately and
systematically so
a lot of critique criticism critique
critic all those elements there and
notice it's reflexive for dewey
i also want to point out one other thing
in the dewey right philosophy is and can
be nothing
that phrase occurs so many times in the
history of philosophy
where philosophers attempt to legislate
what philosophy could be
and as it turns out it always escapes
those
those strictures finally alfred north
whitehead
an attitude of mind towards doctrines
ignorantly
entertained isn't that an interesting
idea we
ignorantly entertain doctrines
teachings ideas and then we adopt an
attitude of mind towards them and that's
philosophy
there are three others that i thought
would be kind of interesting to bring up
from poets and and theologians novalis
says
really homesickness and urge to be at
home
everywhere we make through
philosophizing
things that are not our home into our
home
t.s eliot gave a kind of nonsensical one
the purple bullfinch and the lilac tree
sounds almost
you know zen-like doesn't it and then
finally
paul tillich the theologian that
cognitive approach to reality in which
reality
as such is the object again a very
metaphysical
emphasis there getting at the reality
that is only being dealt with piecemeal
by the other
sciences and disciplines now notice
all these definitions or character
characterizations of philosophy
there's something to them we can go into
them we can explain them we can derive
some benefit from them
none of them manage to apply to
everything that we call
philosophy so that should lead us to be
a little bit leery
of demanding definitions right off the
bat
perhaps and here's what i would suggest
coming from plato
some definitions we can begin with and
other definitions
we have to work our way towards them and
it may not happen
at the end of a week or reading of
several books it may take us a long time
and we may need to revise those
definitions that we generate
along the way
you